hey everyone the title of spider-man
homecoming sequel has been revealed it's
spider-man far from home now what does
this tell us about the next spider-man
movie and what other big updates from
the movie came out this week we're gonna
tell you everything that we know about
spider-man 2 but first welcome to new
rockstars news it's our deep dive into
all the biggest stories this week so
we're also gonna talk about what's going
on with the Star Wars movies also Luke
Cage season 2 and a revealing set photo
from Wonder Woman 2 and a lot of other
stuff that we learned I'm Erik Bosse
joining me at this table are Sam back
over here hello what what's up it's
Maude Maude Garrett hand on hip
I'm DJ well when did we become awkward
we do this every week guys yeah yeah and
for those of you join us last week at
VidCon oh so great seeing you we're back
in our studio here go check out our
video on episode it was so great tad to
meet you guys in person to hand out
these spared by thanos wristbands and we
got like a whole bunch more yes and
catch it back there rubbery don't catch
it did you say to you have got about
half lift yeah yo yeah that's so perfect
it's the ones that weren't spared by
that and speaking of fairness and what
comes next let's get started with our
top story the sequel to spider-man
homecoming this week Tom Holland
released an Instagram video for fans
while holding a tablet containing the
script for spite him in the sequel
showing its title page or really the
title to be spider-man far from home now
first people were wondering if this was
like an intentional prank of some kind
given Tom Hollands history with
accidental spoilers in a passage on
press junkets but uh yeah Marvel had
Kevin Feige confirmed far from home to
be the movie's actual title he said that
they liked how it ties into the title
home Co ties it into the title like
homecoming like there's multiple
meanings to the phrase far from home
would mean a lot of different things
Feige also said that in the movie Peter
Parker would be going to Europe with his
friends on summer vacation now we know
that the movie will be based in London
and it will likely feature Jake
Gyllenhaal as a villain Mysterio that
hasn't been confirmed but it sounds like
that's gonna be the case also the return
of Michael Keaton as
the vulture oh it sounds like that will
be happening as well now when asked
about how spider-man far from home will
fit in with the MCU timeline at first
Kevin Feige was a little cryptic
he then implied that it would take place
after infinity war and Avengers 4 he
compared it to Peters arc and homecoming
you know that was in the aftermath of
Civil War showing how it affects his
teenage life it looks like this next
movie will go through something similar
maybe an analogous situation what do you
guys think far from home could refer to
I think that's a big question right now
and you know after Tony Stark played a
role in homecoming what avenger MCU
character would you like to see paired
up with spider-man in the sequel Eric
that was a great summary thank you very
much hey I don't I don't mind the title
I like if the home is the thing we're
gonna be playing with over a trilogy
that's not the worst made this joke
seven times now here's number eight
would like it to be homeward bound so
you could team up with animal characters
anything moving on I wouldn't mind
extend seas in Europe he's closer to
Africa than America is in Black Panther
come up it becomes yeah and also since
he can like we saw him run on like the
side of buildings in Korea when it's
chasing down Klaw and his men and be
kind of fun to see him running across
like buildings in London or in like
Paris if they wanted to do that as well
good bye fun black panther running along
black panther with spider-man swinging
it'd be really good a little bit of that
I feel in Avengers with vision in
Ireland yes my lifestyle in Scotland
yeah I really liked that Davis the side
of what we usually get I like seeing
that we have infiltrating different
parts of the world um do do I like the
home being the theme I mean he doesn't
spend much time at home does he and
there wasn't actually a homecoming in
homecoming was there he didn't go you
know I don't want this anymore you know
multiple meetings like spider-man
homecoming was his home coming back to
Marvel homecoming dance and then far
from home what if I what's the more he's
gonna be off he would be boys growing up
I guess so I don't know well I think
entitle the only yeah I wasn't crazy
about the title either though
you know they had said that there was
going to be like a pattern to it and we
all expect there's gonna be like school
things you know that's grub this summer
breakers Spring Break or road trip or
euro trip or something you know I don't
know in the in the offices we were
joking and there's like this improv
warm-up game where you try to build a
pattern and you start with like one word
and you tried to build a pattern off
that word so it'd be like homecoming
Spring Break summer vacation but some
people don't get what the pattern is
sometimes far from home to escape from
New York I think I mean tonight I'm
sorry but if it's gonna be like a home
alone version and he's setting up traps
for Boulder and stuff like that
count me slips on his Legos or something
that he puts an actual spider on his
face and vulture screams like Daniel
Stern did oh yeah for that yeah it's
real good it's very violent
yes really they should be dead yeah
first time around yeah yeah well I think
if our from home to me implies maybe
we'll be getting some kind of flashbacks
to wherever Peter went you know in the
theory is now because if he's either
dead or they're gonna bury one time or
he's in some other kind of like realm or
dimension and maybe that will traumatize
him in some way to raise like he's
literally back where in this world but
like mentally still having
reverberations of where he wasn't far
from home and some other element
literally got him maybe he's dealing at
TSD of literally yeah yeah I don't I
don't know if I need that a spider-man
movie also I think the way people do the
headlines for these articles like Kevin
Feige that says the characters that died
or what they vanished
they vanished no they died that's what
van ish means that all of the matter is
being transported or disappears in one
in particular spot but this there is
residue Tony Stark actually took a name
and you got a lot of computer
in there I characterize it as banished
well I think in that moment you know
they didn't really know what like they
wanted us to feel confused about what
happened they died as much as anybody it
can die in these movies but yeah
realistically they can't be dead dead no
one ever really dies that's why it's
called Ned that's irony to a pin cushion
though so he seems pretty dead I did not
see that to come no he didn't
that's the crossover I would love get
the proper quick syllabi yes I did enjoy
I don't know if you guys saw this my
boss logic you know he's the guy he does
all the really cool edits of characters
and what a nice very talented Photoshop
he did one where it's Peter on an alien
world after he came like back if he
popped back up in the university to be
back at the planet where he died and you
saw the symbiote crawling up him and you
see him looking on his face I'm like oh
that's cool far from home as in being
like in space but a space spider-man
movie is he most of his stuff is based
on gravity so when you get him in a
place where gravity he can't like use
momentum around it's still fun but it's
like he can't do that much like we got a
little bit of it in Infinity Ward going
between in zero-g or light zero
simulated gravity that's called alien
moment they come mm-hmm yeah I mean if
we think like fun cars in the first
homecoming movie we had of course Tony
Stark and we had the video of Captain
America where he was like on the gym
training video like it could be fun to
see Hulk I've heard people float the
idea of dr. strange which would make
sense because they've met each other now
and that'd be of fun if for probably
most kids that grew up when I grew up
your exposure to dr. strange was him
teaming up with spider-man and
spider-man comic you read yeah yeah so
that seems that seems like it could be
cool also the London sanctum there's
only three there was Huck Hong Kong New
York and but London sanctum is no longer
if I recall magic you do everyone your
ranking there opening the wakandan
embassy so that could be a really good
way of putting black panther in there
too is everybody Sir Ian Peter hanging
out and because I didn't happen if any
more one quick little question Oh that'd
be a cute couple away one little quick
question I do have is now that we are
already talking about the aftermath aw
of infinity War part two we already know
that they're all coming back does that
mean infinity War part two is like oh we
know how it ends because it's all mapped
out for us and we know if it's going to
be fine or would you prefer that Marvel
stays tight-lipped on absolutely
everything and then you just unfolds as
it unfolds it's tough because they're
gonna be shooting stuff so it's long
it's gonna come out so do you either get
ahead of that or do you just wait for
the leaks to happen if they try and
pretend like these characters are not
coming back I would find that
infuriating yes it's just you know like
don't even find like we know like its
focus on I don't think it matters
knowing the ending as long as the movie
itself is good because if like watching
the first Avengers did we actually think
what he was gonna win in obliterate New
York yeah you know you basically know
how these movies are gonna play out the
journey as long as it's entertaining and
engaging but there's no stakes I
disagree yeah it's it there is a
question of seeing how they get from
point A to point B you know it's
interesting we're all gonna see part
four anyway you know or Part two but in
the fourth Avengers yeah we're gonna see
it just announces the exact release date
and show us a cast photo and we'll see
it I mean it'll make our lives here at
new rock stars where our bread and
butter is breaking down trailers yeah a
little bit harder but whatever it like
it's it presents like almost an
impossible marketing situation for the
next and they started feeling that about
four months ago yeah they're not they're
not doing themselves justice and I had
an instance at with ant-man where they
couldn't answer a particular question
and by not being able to answer it
answered it completely if you know what
I'm saying and that had to do with the
timeline
yeah is that a huge spoiler not really
we've speculated everything under the
under the Sun we're see we're seeing it
soon yeah everything before you do I
swear to god I'll jump out the window
problem with like are they trying to
market the Superman's in it or he's not
in it right and there's arguments that
hurt the movie and other things hurt
that movie anyway I think like a good
way around this is they pulled like a
matrix where it's like Avengers 3 comes
out in the summer and then in the fall
Avengers 4 you know I mean like you you
decrease your window I think they're
gonna spider-man what comes out two
months after Avengers 4 it's all in the
one timeline and this is what Star Wars
isn't doing they're jumping all over the
place so they're not really you know
facing this same situation where they're
trying not to spoil themselves but at
the same time I think the Star Wars
audience which we'll get to is feeling a
little bit confused because it is not
streamlined and seamless I think the
best way to do it it's like get the
question out of the way and the very
first teaser that you release or
Avengers 4 answer that question of did
they die where did they go
just like whatever your this comic book
II solution of what happened and I'm
just answer it in the first shot of the
first trailer so that people aren't
worried about that question like you
know open up with a shot of like Tony
Stark and like all the classic Avengers
get around because we know that's an
article the other day like we we found
out why they these are these Avengers
were the ones that were left it's like
it because they were the originals like
is that a question like yeah anyway and
have Tony be like we need to save them
shows how that's like yeah they're gonna
save them of course they're gonna say
yeah we know that does anybody really
concerned that that's not gonna happen
yes okay let me have childlike wonder I
don't want to go in knowing everyone I
want to have fun I would assume all the
characters I loved died I want to have
fun yes it's like the leftovers or
everyone's just like crying I want to
have that experience that I had watching
book Jedi last Jedi where all the
characters were bad at what they do and
they all saw I want that
again you take that back Jessica move
well we'll be talking about Star Wars in
a bit but yeah let us know down below
what you think far from home could be
referring to on the four different
meanings that Kevin Feige stained but
yeah we'll be talking more about far
from home and of course we'll be talk
about Avengers so hopefully we'll be
gaining a title of that movie that will
probably answer some of these questions
maybe this is the double meaning he's
not only far from home as he's in Europe
but also they're giving the rights back
to Sony so no be far from it but for now
let's move on to this week's trivia
question yeah so here we go it's great
that we all get a chance to answer yeah
okay so this week's trivia okay oh it's
a long one because we have an
announcement in it okay it was announced
this week that Sony plans a movie for
spider-man spin-off character Cindy moon
she's a korean-american girl who gets
bitten by the same radioactive spider
that I its Peter
city actually appeared in a small role
in spider-man homecoming as one of
Peters classmates played by Tiffany s
Penson and when prepping for the
academic decathlon sandy appears right
after Liz says the moons of Saturn and
and one of her few lines in the movie
here's a question one of her few lines
in the movie what physics concept does
Cindy Moon shout as a trivia answer
would you why that's just me we are here
to talk about comic book characters well
later this episode will reveal the
answer of the trivia question we got all
of our answers in the bucket here and
the closest answer as decided by our
judges will George sign off goodbyes in
the in a video meanwhile the loser will
have to cleverly riff on our in other
news headlines oh boy isn't that always
fun keeps your watch and don't it okay
everyone a quick update from the news
this week a set photo from Wonder Woman
to a Wonder Woman 1984 with our first
first look at Kristen Wiig character the
photo was tweeted by director patty
Jenkins we will be plain Barbara Minerva
which is the alias of the villain
cheetah in the photo you can see Wiig
looking up at statues of lions at drafts
and antelopes reflecting the Cheetahs
animalist
predatory nature so yeah and some
eighties clothes and Slappy's yeah I dig
it people be wearing that soon again
very interested to see what cheetah
looks like when she's all cheated out
Sierra's a villain has she ever played
like an actual villain mother
oh yeah antagonistic yes the best way to
describe that she's like the that's a
pretty monster snake yeah yeah I think
it'll be good because uh you know a lot
of the direction they've taken cheetah
recently in the comics is like it makes
you feel sad that she's cheetah and I
think casting somebody's likable is
Kristen Wiig and who looks like I feel
like that looks like a very relatable
person to me and having her turn into a
monster that probably is out to kill
what prior to that moment it was
probably a hero of hers he's gonna hurt
the audience a little bit which looks
like that between that and Steve Trevor
returning it feels like there's gonna be
a lot of yeah right
yeah and it looks like we might have a
trailer for Wonder Woman or some kind of
teaser early early teaser footage at
Comic Con
hold on your butt's okay everybody let's
talk about the future of the Star Wars
franchise this week saw a few big
reports that Lucasfilm could be put in
at standalone Star Wars movies on hold
meaning the announced Boba Fett movie
that was gonna be directed by James
Mangold and the rumored obi-wan Kenobi
movie might not be happening however the
report said that Lucasfilm still planned
on the Star Wars trilogies that are in
development there's one by Rian Johnson
another trilogy by Game of Thrones
showrunners David Benioff and DB Weiss
Johnson's producer Ram Bergman said that
we could be seeing the first of his new
movies as early as two years from now
but when it comes to these standalone
movies solo director Ron Howard said
that the report about them being put on
hold might not be accurate he shrugged
off a negativity about solo saying it
was still the biggest opening of his
career the question is which Star Wars
project area is most looking forward to
like do Star Wars stories need to be
told in trilogy form or can standalone
movies ever be a better option the first
thing is that ABC actually when that
news was announced about two hours later
came forward saying that it wasn't true
at all but that's not worth not
speculating over I have theories
obviously Star Wars likes to play a lot
of things safe and I think that solo was
a bit of a risk and it didn't pay off
and the risk wasn't necessarily in terms
of the script or the storyline it was
the fact that they changed directors
halfway through it was the fact that you
know they're basically focusing on a
character that we've only just seen in
the latest trilogies that we've had I'm
a bit bummed that they didn't kick off
with the obi-wan standalone movie
because you McGregor wanted to play
obi-wan and continue on that role and it
would have been the best way to join and
link the prequels to the current trilogy
it was one of the few things that other
prequels that people still really loved
he acted the crap out of that role and
he didn't have amazing things to go on
but he made it incredible and I just
think that Star Wars really needed
someone like this and then to hear that
Alden Ehrenreich he needed a little bit
of coaching when it came to acting to
try and not mimic Han Solo in the
original by Harrison Ford but to make
his own spin on it so why don't you just
get someone who cannot screw it up or
just avoid the debate altogether you
know people already have accepted you
and McGregor in this room you know you
don't need those Aneta 20 years between
render the Sith and you hope for
punishing on Obi Wan I like the idea of
focusing on these new trilogies not so
much that they're new trilogies but the
idea of focusing on new different things
not like hey you wanna know what no I
really don't I honestly don't care do
you know how solar became solar don't
care yeah I'm super ambivalent know
what's the Kessel run yeah it's so the
idea of like focusing on stuff like
jumping jumping to different points in
time hopefully different sets of
characters different wait because I
think at least to me the appeal of SAR
was when I was younger is this idea of
limitless possibilities and as the
series has gone on you've realized the
possibilities are actually quite limited
apparently because it's always the same
set of stories so if we could shake that
up in an interesting engaging way I'm
all for it well I mean I also think that
standalone movies you're right they're
telling stories that we didn't
necessarily want to hear but they're
also a big full stop at the end of it
when you have a trilogy you are telling
us you know a story that actually can be
that can be fleshed out that can have an
arc Oh home sorry over three movies and
that's why I think Marvel's been so
successful is because the storyline it's
can its concurrent you know it's it's
going in the order that it's all
happening the events are going back
they're not jumping back and forward and
Star Wars is at the moment you had your
original trilogy which was the Skywalker
saga pretty much and then you went back
and realized Daddy Skywalker his story
so basically the trilogy of Anakin and
your understanding this like family tree
a lot better and then now it was
supposed to
I passed the baton on to the next sort
of Skywalker trilogy I only didn't find
out that he's not a Skywalker at all
what and I do think that movie goers do
appreciate having a full complete story
over three movies because you can put
more attention and love into it yeah
that does seem to be the case at least
that's how Disney is looking at it I
think in general the rule of thumb seems
to be trilogies or franchises as opposed
to just standalone stories and I mean as
I we've been rewatching these Star Wars
movies since the force awakens has come
out just the original Star Wars the 1977
Star Wars was a standalone movie there
was no expectation to make a sequel out
of it there was some kind of like
creative freedom to Lucas's working and
all the actors work and I'ma be true
it's like we don't know what this is
let's just embrace the weirdness and
just kind of like go with it and when
you know we saw the Death Star blow up
for most people who saw that movie when
it came out that was as far as this
universe is gonna go because it's
important to note that when that four
movie first came out it didn't have the
Episode four or whatever is Italy Star
Wars you know ya jumped right into it
and I I think it is possible to do a
standalone movie that that could work I
think will you also run into issues when
you put the trilogy expectations on it
that things will end in a way that's
satisfying like crossing over from the
force awakens to the last Jedi I think
some of the issues people are having
with the last Jedi is it didn't answer
all the questions like yeah you gave it
to two different filmmakers JJ said Ryan
Johnson you don't have to answer these
questions do whatever you want with it
and then you kind of set up some fans to
get upset when you know people take it
in another direction or at least with
one movie you just have one Phil
maker in charge of where it's where the
story's gonna go you have beginning
middle and end act and that's you know
this industry is based around these
movies that are told in these two-hour
formats and I feel like that's where we
have the most creative control to tell
the story that we want - well that's the
thing is because I think it's I think
the hope for these trilogies is since it
sounds like they're being spearheaded by
and it's like ryan johnson and one and
then Benioff and Weiss and the other
you'll get that because you mentioned
like sketch or whatever you know you've
learned yes and and and between force
awakens and last jet it's more like
instead of yes and it's like no
nevermind
right I don't want to do any of that
there's much a new kerosene and I say no
other way I have all these characters
I've been wanting to do since I was a
kid so here they all are so maybe it
should have been set up by JJ's writers
because I think there's a one of the
things that the Marvel does kind of have
that balance where they have they have a
strong show your honor with with Feige
and so there is even though there there
is that Disney formula that that I
compared to that because that's you
Disney the same formula for the princess
movies and everything you use a little
bit of wiggle room to where at least
superficially Doctor Strange is 100
percent different than Black Panther
mm-hmm yeah and I mean where's like
every Star Wars movie and I think part
of it is your Frida dwith the
expectation of Star Wars yeah
your and I mean it's like if you were
coming out with like hey here's the new
New Testament everybody's like let us
know what you think whether you prefer a
standalone version of the future of Star
Wars or if you really prefer these kind
of stories grouped in threes and what do
you think maybe is the difference
between the way these Star Wars
franchises are being rolled out as as
opposed to the other franchises that we
know like Marvel and in the DC movies
and another quick update from this week
a poster for the upcoming M night
Shyamalan movie glass was released this
is the third movie of the unbreakable
and split superhero universe and it's
coming January 18 2019 now glass will
focus on samuel l.jackson as mr. glass
AEK Elijah price
he's the physically fragile but comic
book obsessed terrorist mastermind from
unbreakable it will also feature Bruce
as David Dunn he's the invulnerable hero
of unbreakable who remember showed up at
the end of split and James McAvoy is the
villain Kevin Crowe McKay the horde he
has a type of super split personality
disorder in split which is really really
cool movie that you should check out I
didn't really spoil anything for you
just go check out the movie and now this
poster features the three men and
restraints with their reflections on the
floor revealing their super heroic or
supervillainess selves and the tagline
you cannot contain what you are was like
a Photoshop Teran
he's got the V lady but the V's he's got
is good it's been how long since I'm
breakable like I was he gonna rip in ten
years yeah when the time I was waiting
for Aang from The Last Airbender to just
zoom fast cuz obviously these are all
their characters from his most
successful movies and I think that it
seemed being like hey remember that I
actually can make a good movie and now
by their forces combined and I kind of
loved the fact that we have so many
superhero movies at the moment but this
for some reason seems very refreshing
yeah it's really so different I love
that I love this is a great way to set
up a connection humors like you have to
hear a movie now you got the villain
movie now they fight I mean I'm so yeah
I'm so Sony tricked us into you know
watching this movie we didn't know it
was an unbreakable sequel and you're
gonna do it again I don't think yeah it
was it was so special and like split for
what it is when it's kind of it's
dabbling into mental health but they do
Emma I did the work to be like hey
immediately when I explained what his
condition is it's otherworldly like
there's something that's different about
it like it's not it's not really talking
about mental illness it's talking about
this specific patient right it has
something very strange going on absolute
personality is that one of them happens
to be like a supernatural
well that but it's also like turning a
mental illness into like a monstrous
thing this person has and I get the
criticism also his disease in in our
world it's very highly
debated because it might not be real
there is there's a version of it yeah
but there's a lot of debate its
controversial so that's why the movie
had a lot of trouble going in like being
released but he did the work to be like
it try to separate that for a second
because he's got something else going on
right but that was I thought I
appreciate that and I'm excited to see
the kind of work you put into this yeah
it's also interesting you talked about
them being in restraints it's
interesting the idea that like you look
at that poster I could almost imagine a
twist that like all this stuff has been
their own mental baggage sure like you
haven't done David done never really had
the powers like they're all just because
they all look kind of they look like
they're in a mental hospital yes you
know yeah I mean it does definitely
suggest a psychological take on these
characters powers as opposed to like a
stunt physical spectacle based ones I
love the idea I think some things I'm
most excited about is the girl shoes
from the which I'm just point them Anna
Taylor joy yeah being kind of like David
Dunn's like sidekick right yeah yeah
okay everyone Luke eight season two is
now on Netflix and it might be one of
the few Marvel Netflix series to top its
first season now some are saying it's
one of the best seasons of this whole TV
universe season two picks up with Luke
after the events of the defenders in
which he has now cleared his name he's
dealing with the idea of being a local
celebrity in Harlem and he faces Mariah
Alfre Woodard and bushmaster Mustafa
Shakir both are amazing actors who carry
the show in my opinion Lucy Liu actually
gets directs the first episode in season
and like in season 1 the show seems to
continue this tradition of cultural rich
storytelling in a way that maybe the
other shows don't necessarily have that
tone specifically as fleshed out but I
want to hear from you all and Sam and DJ
I know you guys have talked a lot about
this in your podcast I want to know what
you identify as the hidden strength of
Luke Cage season 2 how does it rank
among the other Marvel Netflix series
that are out there for me what made this
season season really special that in
season 1 a lot of people criticize that
at about episode 7 it drops off because
voice for a character I don't spoil that
for you what you just need to know is
that they pivot and they try to
introduce a new character and it
kinda doesn't live up to what we saw how
great this show could be for some people
watching I was more fine with it but I
understood in this Chiyo hidari Cocker
the showrunner he is he's amazing he
really listened to criticism and he
changed it up so as the shows going you
have Mustafa Shakir's bushmaster a
Mariah and shades Houthi Arras is great
- that there's kind of like this like
it's like a wheel that's spinning it's
like as soon as you kind of get like
like oh where are we at with this
character it's like it's okay we're
gonna take a break for a second in time
and like meet these people and see what
their deal is and it never really widens
too far where you can't keep track of
where everybody is like daredevil season
1 you have like five different families
you have to like try to keep track of
like this Japanese families the Chinese
family this is like the Italians
everything and so it's like yeah and
this it's like you just kind of just
cycle through it and it feels really
nice also in every fictional thing we
watch you have the villain saying oh
we're not so different
yeah but instead of saying it shows and
it shows that this person's going down
this path and this is how they were
raised and you see where Luke set and
you're like y'all are actually do you
are actually doing the same thing just
on the opposite side of the coin without
telling us you're showing us and it
makes me feel smarter watching it
because you're like Luke is this close
to maybe moving over and this person's
real close to being a good person
actually changing the life for the
better but you're like stop teetering so
close it was it's not I think this
season is the most consistent and well
built where it it accelerates to the end
from episode 3 on it's it's fantastic
ya know I think it's I think it's easily
one of the best Marvel Netflix shows
it's up there I think it ties for me
with Punisher with Jessica Jones still
probably be the first season Jessica
Jones tour probably being been up but I
think it executes all the stuff it's
trying to excuse you really well it
moves its story in interesting
directions whereas a lot of these
Netflix show is kind of like you feel
the mileage yeah and 12 episodes always
feels just a little bit too long yeah
and this one moves in interesting
American directions it uses its place
within these other shows really well by
incorporating other characters from
other like it it works like that you
want a comic book show to work where
characters from these other shows kind
of poppy and occasionally like Iron Fist
and apparently it wasn't abysmal no
was invisible but other characters that
you wouldn't expect pot like like from
supporting characters from other shows
pop in for like an episode or whatever
the way it builds out of supporting cast
is really interesting
Musha officer here's great as as
bushmaster he's fantastic in his fight
scenes yeah he'd physically like there's
a scene where he's shirtless and he's
like it I think what's happening is he's
watching a fight that Luke has and he's
like trying to mimic a way to try to get
around like he's just he's like
fortitude and he's like moving around
and like you see all of his muscles
rippling and you're like you're like but
like I think Mike Colter and Mustafa's
they got in a fight Mike Colter would
lose extremely fast but it's already
like a big presence anyways yeah and I
think but the the villain the villain of
this season and I would I would argue
possibly the villain of Luke Cage the
series is offering water does Mariah
Dillard and she's in its interest
catchers the way it builds out the
relationships the way that you have
villains but you understand it doesn't
let them off the hook but you understand
where they're coming from and why they
are and the way it flushes out its
community I think makes it a really
engaging show in the direction it takes
its character and is is very I would say
there's some similarities to daredevil
season two but I think the way it
executes that and gets you there is more
perhaps better yeah you mentioned
something about fleshing out the
community I think the world building on
this show is unlike most of the other
shows and compared to some of them it's
easier to build a world than a TV show
than in a movie because you you know
limited time but you really it's not
like they're creating a new world
they're just accurately depicting a
world that it's already there and for
someone like me yes that is a new world
yeah I don't know Harlem that well but
it's nice to see it feels authentic yeah
and the characters like they connect to
each other in what feels like an
authentic believable way and that
enriches the show and such a wonderful
with like you see what would happen if a
superhero in Harlem was suddenly sprung
up on the map how would the whole
community react to that and everything
seems thought-out it seems like there's
a very rich show Bible that they created
for the news and there's little things
like there's a new character they
introduced named piranhas that's a minor
character and he's the worst but he's my
favorite like he's okay he's like the
fast-talking like a bookie for somebody
basically where he's just like
he's always smiling come on man anything
like he's the biggest smile in the world
but you know that you're like yeah I
want to slap you yeah he's a little so
bad little scumbag but you love them you
don't I mean the biggest smile these
guys you gotta watch its piranha
for a reason it's just like I don't have
the teeth pot I will make a point which
like the world building I did feel in
daredevil season one it was almost like
a drinking game every time they
mentioned Hell's Kitchen you know it was
like if we say it enough and that'll
flesh it all out I really liked with in
Luke Cage season one how there was
always music as like a sort of flowing
theme throughout each episode and really
really projected a tone from the get-go
are we seeing that in season two because
I haven't seen it yet I'm sorry yeah
it's really well integrate and they also
use music to distinguish because
bushmaster comes from Jamaica so his his
culture is different than what Luke is
you students so they use music to
distinguish that as well and it's just
everything about it feels more confident
it feels like the showrunner really like
looked at what worked and what didn't
season one and just any season one was
already solid but really emphasized what
worked and like dialed back the stuff
that didn't play yeah but now it's time
to move on to our new rock stars news
lightning round
you guys are tweeting us some questions
I'm gonna fire them at my co-host have
to answer them as quickly and without
hesitation as possible is everyone ready
yes here we go
for Sam ads if uu wants to know would
you rather have fingers for hair or hair
for fingers these are the kind of
questions I like for singers what would
be the word of hair for think can I move
is it prehensile amazing that work I
think it's just like skin that just
grows out of knob like pom-poms if it
was a nail at least I could be like yeah
or I could pick us up up and with hair
it's just like I can't even tell get it
together yeah pinkies cuz then I'd be
like I do head stands way more often
secondary
[Applause]
can you pass me my hat thank you and you
just see we need A's hey come over here
I need to talk to you come here oh good
question
meanwhile the one person that said
everything is like how do you do
anything all right for mod at Sunday
duck wants to know do you have any odd
and/or hidden talents yeah here's the
thing that my party trick and this is
what I did to literally get my first job
in television because I said what is
your party trick and I just went like
this I made my hand disappear oh sorry
did I biggest smile nope she has a small
if only you had hair fingers he could
fit if Tina wants to know which
superhero was your ultimate crush when
you were younger
probably Psylocke yeah
Oh is there a lot of comics when I was
becoming growing up and learning about
they come hang on yeah yeah I think I
think psylocke was one that stood out to
me because you read those scribe harem
costume for me uh it had nothing to do
with the costumer it was just no yeah it
was all her personality you know she was
strong-willed she was determined she had
the ninja vibe which was cool you know I
mean I yeah yeah yeah
so outside yeah she she wore basically
not so like a onesie similar to what you
could get at what clothing and for me
you want to read with o Ali men Rica's
says how has new rock stars as a whole
impacted your own life lightning but
lightning as a whole well it's given me
a really cool job where I get to work
with really really cool people those on
screen and off and I get to like watch
like the favorite movies that I already
watch and get to like and geek out on
them so it's giving me like a cold job
that I don't have to like dread going
into work every day so yeah that's
that's it it's given me a lot more
Twitter followers
[Applause]
between us your questions and people
look out for our tweets every week where
we want to we want to hear from you guys
and we want to interact with you guys
and and hopefully like we did at VidCon
last week we might be doing some live
shows in the future that was really fun
if we can tweet us if you want if you
would go to that okay I guess that's
what I'm curious about
we'll come to you we'll find you but
next up let's take a look at what we got
in the pipeline for videos coming out on
this channel the next week well at the
end of next week is ant-man and the wasp
so we'll be doing some videos on that
we'll look at the post-credits Jimmy
tell you it excited well also for this
show we'll be doing our group review of
the movie what we thought our what we
liked what we wish we saw more of we're
also gonna be doing a video about enough
theory we haven't had about Avengers 4
and possibly Kronos for the Marvel
Comics could Chronos factor into this
movie and we'll have another special
announcement video about our upcoming
re-watch of the Dark Knight trilogy so
keep an eye out for that and then yeah
for any trailers that come up in these
next couple weeks before Comic Con we
will be looking at those as well yeah
and now comes the time for our 15
seconds shout out where each of us is 15
seconds to shout out plug or ramble
about anything we want Sam why don't you
start I said this at the VidCon live
show but I want to recommend a podcast
without that podcast I've been download
all oh geez oh no it's bad it's nope and
I want to say it again can I listen to
it all week oh geez and you can learn
about different ologists from all around
the world you can learn about the
science of laughter which is really
interesting and learn about the science
of the huge squids sexology who's really
interesting you know I don't like the
urology it was great the piure ology I
learned how to conquer my fear so I'm
afraid of nothing now there's a reason
why science has SCI in it that's it
download it
the my 15 seconds out out the trailer
for the movie Mandy did anybody see this
no I'm Oh Nicholas Kate it's like
perfect casting for him it looks like he
yes oh I get some wife or girlfriend of
his away from the devil know what's
going on in this movie it's a horror
action movie there reminds me a lot of
like an evil dead type movie but with
better production value than the first
one at least
so yeah it's perfect for Nicolas Cage
Nicolas Cage screaming a lot so check
out the trailer for Mandy at least for
the trailer my 15 second shot up is Eman
and the wasp I'm not gonna spoil
anything but it was surely a good time
there's a lot of fun a lot of fun and my
shout out especially goes to Michael
Pena you're my boy
also Evangeline Lilly I interviewed her
in Taipei a week or two ago two weeks
ago and she had an amazing story about
being 38 years old and being a superhero
and how and I don't know if you've seen
a lot of those like excerpts from her
other junkets since she's basically like
yeah all the men complain about being in
the suits because they don't wear high
heels and she like kicks F foot up and
she's got like heels that big on but for
me she told a great story about how she
refuses to dye her gray the grays in her
hair and like the cinematographer was
like there's something reflecting on her
on her head can you do something about
it to the makeup artist and she was like
nope she's not letting you cover up her
graze and she goes I call them my
sparkles and I really like that
I am I feel empowered yeah even though
I've yet to have a great yeah my turn
chaos theory comic calm last time I was
on here I talked about it we were on
Kickstarter but now we are on indie
go-go if you went over and supported us
overcooks our last time check the
updates for that because you have an
opportunity to get a special bonus perk
but if you've heard about me talking
about it before and you didn't go over
well go to chaos theory comic calm right
now it's the new comic I'm trying to Rey
I'm trying to give you guys something
new fun entertaining this is volume 2
so there's zombies fighting dinosaurs
and aliens and other stuff that I can't
mention each each chapter I tried to do
something bigger and crazier than the
lashes and flaming chain so there is a
flaming chainsaw it's everything I
wanted to see in in comics and movies
and just something big and fun with
characters that you can relate to and
honor are entertaining and enjoyable and
for new rockstars Watchers if you go
over and contribute $20 or more actually
yeah it should contribute $20 or more
and leave a comment that says you're
from new rock stars you will get this
postcard map of the United States in
this world because it's gone with
zombies and dinosaurs and aliens tearing
it up it's gone through some stuff so it
has a bunch of backstory that you can't
find in the comic and it's just a big
fun time I think we're at 78% now so
close yeah that sounds like my high
school grade
just help me Entertain You Let Me
Entertain You also I'm gonna slogan for
it by the way we do flame soul yeah I
came flame saw I conquered there's a
stretch goal yeah if we get the funding
the stretch goal is going to be Sam's
gonna write and draw his own comic 40
pages 40 promising like to clarify that
Sam has not written or drawn a comic
before have you drawn at all everyone
had to take a finger-painting class or
something
I know I've used watercolors before
it'll be great so if you want to see Sam
do that and you want to get that
contribute to the comic then we can
reach our stretch goal 40 pages what I
have to promise that it's promise on
camera I have to do it chaos theory
comic doctor Oh check it out we should
just end the show now yeah ask the
questions in the first act you answer
them by the end classic storytelling
that's mine so we're gonna revisit our
trivia question
that's mods and this is
so our trivia question that we asked
earlier regard to Cindy moon and
spider-man homecoming what trivia answer
did she yell out while they were
prepping for the decathlon academic
decathlon on the bus let's see what we
it was a physics concept so what was the
physics came was a gun to my head right
so what let's do we all said Eric said
Newton's third law what is that that's
isn't that equal and opposite reaction
reaction there's an equal and opposite
reaction but I thought that was an
emotional thing
okay wait why is there two have to be
good at science get ahead people Sam
said relativity or laws of motion
they're two different things two
different things
see reaction reaction has a reaction
I can read woody gyro what did he write
madro force equals money yeah it does
it's out in the Star Wars universe savez
yeah
the second law of thermodynamics come on
who's furthest pretty trivial so none of
us got it right
unlike last week but you're the best
with the joke the science behind it
amazing closer we just wrote force put
two answers and apparently that's like
how find the closest of us probably I
said laws of motion you said Newton's
second he's an insect my equal and
opposite reaction from every I said
grant he said gravity thermodynamics is
force just like it's
yes it'll never do which I think
involves gravity actually anti-gravity
and relativity huh okay so I'll do our
good-byes and so mod will have to do are
in other news trivia question will have
Sam maybe read line one mods gonna have
to come up with a clever punchline to
follow each one to cleverly riff on it
is everyone ready for it yes okay so Sam
whenever you're all ready yeah take it
away
number one Kevin Feige confirmed that
Marvel does plan to make a second Doctor
Strange movie which will take place
several years after infinity war mod
they're calling it dr. odd yeah because
the odd number of years yep it's good so
far it's not your step above whenever we
try to do this when I have panic attacks
to Jared Leto we'll start right to Jared
Leto will star in a movie as Morbius the
living vampire another spider-man
spin-off character that he says won't
affect his commitment to playing the
yolk terror okay I've got I'm piecing it
together I'm just trying to round about
wait tell Jared letter to Jared let go
of playing the jerk I know I'm saying
yeah I actually would prefer him playing
the living vampire because he already
pretty much is one is he aged no is he
alive
yes people with chalk white skin
apparently and he likes the young blood
three guardians of the galaxy director
James Gunn
Jimmy Gunn has finished the script for
guardians volume three and plans to
shoot start shooting in early 2019 I
heard it took him ages to write the
script because he couldn't figure out
what to call the movie because volume 1
volume 2 volume 3 any patterns with
sequels as we know was spider-man could
be very difficult to follow yeah
Indiana Jones movie will be released
sometime after its scheduled 2020
deadline it will be written by solo
co-writer Jonathan Kasdan why do I have
to make the jokes when Sam already is
one zing
feels like a little knife to the gut
number five Mark Hamill and Chris Evans
got in a playful debate on Twitter over
whether Luke Skywalker's lightsaber
could cut Captain America's shield this
is why we don't bugga Sam's having a
blast while Michael has having a blast
uh wait
lightsaber bugga apparently they both
win it just depends on what universe
you're in is it's burger like the F word
somewhere else no it's like bloody hell
it's a it's a PG rated one performances
on either side of the aisle well thank
you all at home for watching this week's
episode of new rockstars news how should
I do the goodbyes you I don't know
you're a winner I don't know what that
feels like one before yeah
let's see how did when he was one of
Sam's voices that he's just introduced
to him as the news is also my impression
of Sam did it yes I want to thank our
host Jim yeah sure at Sam basher era
class at da bus Maude Garrett at Mont
Garrett and DJ Aldridge at knee Jane
young - maybe slow though worse they
come a little bit coming down below
tweet us any rock stars like this video
share it around and subscribe to new
rock stars for our deep dives in all the
stuff you love guys see you next week
bye bye we made it yeah we made down
Billy Oh Danny Boyle
damn Danny Boyle we only owe